Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. It is the 4th of January and we are ploughing through the 12 days of Christmas. As you can probably tell, the sheer pressure of recording all these 12 days of Christmas podcasts has led to me partially losing my voice. But that's fine because Tom Holland loves to talk. No, but my voice is going as well
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天是1月4日，我们正在经历圣诞节的12天。正如你所听到的，录制所有这些圣诞12天播客的巨大压力导致我的声音有点沙哑。不过没关系，因为汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）很喜欢说话。不，不过我的声音也快哑了
oh no Tom the Jeopardy sexy husk well yes like Margaret Thatcher's voice yes very very like that very like Mrs Thatcher going very very very very very rough voice Tom I think you've been doing splendidly you've been doing wonderfully well
哦，不，汤姆，那种危险而性感的沙哑。哦，是的，就像玛格丽特·撒切尔的声音。是的，非常非常像那个，非常像撒切尔夫人的声音，变得非常非常非常非常粗糙。汤姆，我觉得你表现得棒极了，你做得非常出色。
thank you very pleased with you thank you would you give us please your events that happen on this day in history and make it a good one tom yeah so today is um it's the day that solomon northrup regained his freedom january the 4th 1853 and solomon northrup will be familiar to anyone who has seen steve mcqueen's oscar-winning film 12 years a slave so this is um the terrible story of um black man in born in new york state um freeborn um he's a farmer uh he was also a very proficient violinist and this was the
谢谢，对你的表现非常满意，谢谢。你能给我们讲讲历史上今天发生的事件吗？选个精彩的，汤姆。好的，所以今天呢，是所罗门·诺瑟普（Solomon Northup）重获自由的日子——1853年1月4日。看过史蒂夫·麦奎因（Steve McQueen）获得奥斯卡奖的电影《为奴十二年》的人都会对所罗门·诺瑟普感到熟悉。所以这是一个……关于一个黑人的可怕故事，他出生在纽约州，是个自由人，是个农民，他也是个非常出色的提琴手，而这正是——
the key to what then happens um he's played by chibetel Ejiofor in the, in the film. Um, and Solomon Northrup, he is, uh, so his mother is freeborn woman. Um, his father is a freed slave. There's absolutely no question about the fact, you know, he's not, he's not in any way a slave. He's completely a free man. Um, he marries, um, a woman called Anne Hampton, who's a kind of mix of of black white native american um she's a cook um so they're they're kind of they're i guess kind of they're kind of lower lower class but they're you know they're not on the breadline at all right um and uh they have they're very happily married um and in 1841, because, as I mentioned, he has this proficiency at the violin,
这一切的关键所在。在电影中，他由切瓦特·埃加福（Chiwetel Ejiofor）扮演。所罗门·诺瑟普，他的母亲是一位自由女性，他的父亲是一个获得自由的奴隶。毫无疑问，你知道的，他绝不是什么奴隶。他是一个完全自由的人。他与一个叫安·汉普顿（Anne Hampton）的女人结了婚，她有点黑人、白人和美国原住民的混血，她是一个厨师，所以他们某种程度上……我猜他们算是下层阶级，但他们绝对不是那种食不果腹的人，对吧？而且他们结婚非常幸福。在1841年，因为正如我所提到的，他精通小提琴，
he's offered us a job as a musician in Washington, D.C. And Washington, D.C., of course, is that much further south than New York. And so, therefore, closer to the line where slavery is where where slaves um where they have big slave markets I think yeah and basically it turns out that um the people who've offered uh Solomon Luthorip this job are they're crooks and that they've ordered him because they want to sell him as a slave so they um they they get him to washington dc under this false prospectus they drug him they kidnap him they sell him and he gets shipped to new orleans uh and you can imagine it's just i mean the most terrible thing to happen uh and in new orleans he is uh bought by benedict cumberbatch right so uh william prince ford who is a baptist minister yeah um and
有人在华盛顿特区为他提供了一份音乐家的工作。华盛顿特区当然比纽约更往南，因此更接近那个拥有奴隶制、拥有大型奴隶市场的边界线，我想是的。基本上结果证明，那些给所罗门·诺瑟普提供这份工作的人是骗子，他们引诱他是为了把他当奴隶卖掉。所以他们以这个虚假的招聘信息把他骗到华盛顿特区，给他下药，绑架了他，把他卖掉，他被运到了新奥尔良。你可以想象，这简直是……可以说是最可怕的事情了。在新奥尔良，他被本尼迪克特·C·库伯奇（指本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇）买下了，对吧？所以……威廉·普林斯·福特（William Prince Ford），他是一位浸信会牧师，对吧？而且——
baptists generally you know certainly in the north they're they're very kind of abolitionists they're very much at the kind of the front line of opposing slavery and um ford is a troubled slave owner i think it would be fair to say. And in due course, when Northrop writes up his memoirs, 12 Years a Slave, he writes of William Ford, in my opinion, there never was a more kind,
浸信会的人通常，当然在北方，他们非常倾向于废奴主义，他们很大程度上处于反对奴隶制的最前沿。福特是一个内心纠结的奴隶主，这样说应该很公平。后来，当诺瑟普写下他的回忆录《为奴十二年》时，他这样评价威廉·福特：“依我之见，世上绝无比威廉·福特更善良、更高尚、更坦诚的基督徒了。”
noble, candid Christian man than William Ford. The influences and associations that had always surrounded him blinded him to the inherent wrong at the bottom of the system of slavery. It's kind of, from our perspective, an amazing couple of sentences for someone to write gracious yeah yeah but i mean i think it
“那些一直环绕着他的环境和交往，使他盲目地看不到奴隶制体系本质上的错误。”从我们的角度来看，一个人能写出这样一番宽容的话，这几句话真是太惊人了。是的，是的，但我的意思是，我认为这——
brings home just how radical and upheaval the kind of the assumptions that come to underpin abolitionism are that people had taken the institution of slavery for granted for so long yeah that it was perfectly possible to accept that a man could be um a kind noble candid christian man and still think that slavery was fine yeah of course yeah i mean it's a huge theme that i think we're going to do an episode on slavery at some point and it won't surprise you to know that i do think that the wellsprings of abolitionism are deeply Christian. Tom, I don't think you're alone in that. I mean, that's hardly, of all your views, that's probably the least controversial.
它让人深刻体会到废奴主义所依凭的那些观念经历了一场多么激进的巨变。人们竟然长期将奴隶制这个制度视为理所当然，以至于完全可以接受一个人既是一个善良、高尚、坦诚的基督徒，同时又认为奴隶制没问题。是的，当然，是的。我的意思是，这是一个宏大的主题，我想我们会在某个时候做一集关于奴隶制的节目，你不会惊讶地听到，我确实认为废奴主义的源泉深深植根于基督教。汤姆，我想你在这点上并不孤单。我的意思是，在你的所有观点中，这大概是最不具争议的一个了。
But obviously, Christian arguments are also used to justify slavery. Yeah. And so this figure, you know, this Baptist minister is kind of an interesting figure for that reason. So what then happens is that Ford gets into financial difficulties. And so he sells Northrop on to this carpenter called John Thibode, who is, he's a wanker. Am I allowed to say, I used that word, didn't I? It's like the guy who stole the turkey out of your car. I think he's probably even worse than that.
但显而易见的是，基督教的论点也被用来为奴隶制辩护。是的。所以这个人物，你知道的，这个浸信会牧师出于这个原因是一个相当有趣的人物。接下来发生的事情是，福特陷入了财务困境，于是他把诺瑟普转卖给了一个名叫约翰·蒂贝茨（John Tibbs）的木匠，而这个人是个混蛋。我能这么说吗？我用了那个词，不是吗？就像那个从你车里偷火鸡的家伙。我觉得他可能比那个还要糟糕。
Even worse, my word. Even worse than that um and tibbott is i mean he's an absolute brute he um he almost uh lynches um uh northrop um but they have a fight or something don't they have a fight yeah and uh but fort comes cuts uh cuts northrop down um so he's kind of playing the the good guy there and then Tibbett sells him on to um a plantation owner called Edwin Epps and in the film he's played by Michael Fassbender yeah you know I mean Michael Fassbender always plays the kind of character you don't want to be sold to as a slave yeah he played Mabette didn't he? Yeah, he did. And he played Magneto, I think, in the X-Men. Yeah, I know you're a big superheroes fan, Tom.
甚至更糟，天哪。甚至更糟……蒂贝茨，我的意思是，他是个十足的野蛮人，他差点私刑处死诺瑟普。但他们打了一架什么的，他们不是打了一架吗？是的，打了一架，但福特来把诺瑟普救了下来，所以他某种程度上扮演了好人的角色。然后蒂贝茨又把诺瑟普转卖给了一个叫埃德温·埃普斯（Edwin Epps）的种植园主，在电影中他由迈克尔·法斯宾德（Michael Fassbender）扮演。是的，你知道的，迈克尔·法斯宾德总是扮演那种你绝对不想被当作奴隶卖过去的角色。是的，他演过麦克白，对吧？是的，他演过。而且我想他在《X战警》里演过万磁王。是的，我知道你是个超级英雄迷，汤姆。
So those are the ones that I liked. Those are the ones I saw. Right. So Michael Fassbender plays the young... Who plays the older one? The old Magneto. Is it Ian McKellen or Patrick Stewart? Ian McKellen.
所以那些是我喜欢的。那些是我看过的。好吧。所以迈克尔·法斯宾德扮演年轻的……谁扮演年老的那个？年老的万磁王。是伊恩·麦克莱恩（Ian McKellen）还是帕特里克·斯图尔特（Patrick Stewart）？伊恩·麦克莱恩。
Yes, it's Ian McKellen. Yes, it's Ian McKellen. That's right. So anyway, so this poor guy, Solomon Northrup, he has to work as a slave in Louisiana and 12 years a slave and there he is toiling away 12 years in he meets um a Canadian who's working on the plantation a guy called Samuel Bass and Samuel Bass gets word back to New York Bass is an abolitionist is that right yes right? Yes. And it's a brave thing for him to do because he's breaking Southern law by doing that. Right. Louisiana law. But in New York, the law of the
是的，是伊恩·麦克莱恩。没错，是伊恩·麦克莱恩。对的。所以无论如何，这个可怜的家伙——所罗门·诺瑟普，他必须在路易斯安那州作为一个奴隶劳作，《为奴十二年》，在那里他苦熬了12年。在第12年里，他遇到了一个在种植园工作的加拿大人，一个名叫塞缪尔·巴斯（Samuel Bass）的家伙。塞缪尔·巴斯把消息传回了纽约。巴斯是个废奴主义者，是这样吗？是的，对吧？是的。对他来说，这是一件很勇敢的事，因为他这么做违反了南方的法律。没错，路易斯安那州的法律。但在纽约，该州的法律——
state provides aid to free New York citizens who've been kidnapped and enslaved. So it's obviously a kind of massive thing that's going on i mean it's yeah it's happening so often that there are state provisions to combat it um and so northrop's family and his wife um anne hampton has stayed true to him solomon northrop has stayed true in his love to anne uh so i mean that's kind of very touching story yeah um his fact so so northrop's family and friends they they enlist the aid of the governor of New York guy called Washington Hunt and Northrop gains his freedom on this day in 1853 and his kidnappers you know nothing happens to them they never get punished they never get caught uh so probably hard to track them down I suppose yeah um later in the year
会为被绑架和奴役的自由纽约公民提供援助。所以这显然是一件规模宏大的事情，我的意思是，是的，这种情况发生得太频繁了，以至于有专门的州级法律来打击它。所以诺瑟普的家人和他的妻子——安·汉普顿对忠于他，所罗门·诺瑟普也对安保持着忠贞不渝的爱，所以我的意思是，这是一种非常感人的故事，是的。所以诺瑟普的家人和朋友们寻求了纽约州长的援助，州长名叫华盛顿·亨特（Washington Hunt）。诺瑟普在1853年的今天重获自由，而他的绑架者呢，什么事也没有发生，他们从未受到惩罚，也从未被抓获。所以大概很难追踪到他们吧，我想，是的。在这年晚些时候，
he gets encouraged to to write up the story of what's happened. Yeah. And so 12 Years a Slave, it becomes very significant text in the abolitionist cause. And Northrop, I mean, he does quite a lot of campaigning on it. And then he just kind of fades from the record. And do we know what happened to him? Not really, no. But I suppose the book is his memorial, isn't it?
他受到鼓励，将自己的遭遇写成了故事。是的。因此，《为奴十二年》成了废奴运动中非常重要的文本。诺瑟普，我的意思是，他围绕这个主题做了相当多的宣传活动，然后他就渐渐淡出了公众的视线。我们知道他后来怎么样了吗？并没有，真的不知道。但我想这本书就是他的纪念碑，不是吗？
The book and the film, because the book is one of those slave narratives. But those sort of narratives play a huge part in kind of rousing the hearts and souls of kind of Northern opinion in the years before the Civil War, don't they? Uncle Tom's Cabin, I mean, Uncle Tom's Cabin is obviously slightly different, but those sort of stories of fugitive slaves and sort of that the horrors and the sort of the injustice of it they bring home probably more than any number of tracts non-political kind of unaffiliated people just the horror of the institution don't you think well i think also
这本书和电影，因为这本书是那些奴隶叙事作品之一。但这类叙事在内战爆发前的几年里，在唤醒北方民众的心灵和灵魂方面发挥了巨大的作用，不是吗？《汤姆叔叔的小屋》，我的意思是，《汤姆叔叔的小屋》显然略有不同，但诸如此类的逃亡奴隶的故事，以及那种残酷性和不公正感，比任何数量的政治传单更能让普通、非政治、不属于任何党派的人们深刻感受到这个制度的残酷，你不觉得吗？嗯，我认为也是——
the the particular impact of this is i I mean, obviously most of the narratives, the abolitionist narratives are for white abolitionists, particularly in the North. It's essentially saying, you know, pity the poor black people, the poor black slaves. But they're still, you know, it's very, very difficult for white people in the north to imagine themselves as black slaves yeah but the power of this is that because solomon northrup was a free man yeah in a northern state it therefore becomes much easier for white people in the north to put themselves into his shoes and i think that's the power of it because the shock for northrup isn't that he's been born into slavery or he's been brought from Africa into slavery. He's someone who was born free, who's lived free,
这个事件的独特影响在于，我的意思是，显然大多数叙事，废奴主义叙事都是面向白人废奴主义者的，特别是在北方。它本质上是在说，你知道，去怜悯那些可怜的黑人，可怜的黑奴。但对于北方的白人来说，要让自己想象成黑奴依然是非常、非常困难的。是的，但这个故事的力量在于，因为所罗门·诺瑟普曾是一个自由人，在北方的一个州里，因此北方的白人就更容易将自己代入他的处境中，我想这就是它的力量所在。因为对诺瑟普来说，震惊的不是他生为奴隶，也不是他从非洲被带到奴隶制中。他是一个生而自由、一直过着自由生活的人，
and who then becomes a slave. And I think that, you know, just kind of emotionally perhaps for white readers in the northern states, it makes the horror of what happened to him all the greater. That's a good story. It's a fascinating story. It reminds me a tiny, I mean, I'll tell you a narrative from a century later
而后来却沦为奴隶。我认为，对于北方州的白人读者来说，从情感上讲，这使得发生在他身上的悲剧显得更加残酷。这是一个好故事。这是一个迷人的故事。它让我想起了一个微小的……我的意思是，我给你们讲一个来自一个世纪后的故事，
that has always stuck in my mind. You may not have read it. It's a book called Black Like Me by John Howard Griffin. Have you ever read that? No, I haven't. So this is, again, a book very powerful with white audiences. But the difference here is it's not that um griffin was free and became a slave it was white and then he he literally blacked up so he decided so it's
这个故事一直留在我的记忆中。你可能没读过。这是一本名叫《像我一样黑》（Black Like Me）的书，作者是约翰·霍华德·格里芬（John Howard Griffin）。你读过吗？不，我没有。所以这也是一本对白人读者非常有影响力的书。但不同之处在于，并不是格里芬获得自由然后变成了奴隶，而是他是白人，然后他字面意义上把自己“涂黑”了，所以他决定……
the sort of in the middle of the civil rights movement and he i think it was the 50s 59 he decides he goes to a doctor's friend a doctor friend and a dermatologist and he says basically make me black and they give him um this sort of they give him drugs and he has hours and hours every day under a lamp to sort of darken his skin and then he um he he puts on a stain on top of it and then he basically spends i think something like six weeks um maybe longer uh traveling through the south and describing as a white man what it's like to be treated as a black man yeah and and again it's the kind of story that actually uh because he's not black because
这大约是在民权运动的中间时期，我想大约是50年代，59年。他决定去找一个医生的朋友，一个皮肤科医生，他基本上对他说：“把我变黑。”他们给他提供了一种药物，而且他每天要在灯光下照射好几个小时来使皮肤变暗，然后他在上面涂上一层染料，基本上度过了——我想大概有六周左右的时间，也许更长——他穿行于南方，以一个白人的身份去体验和描述被当作黑人对待是什么感觉。是的。而且，再次强调，这是一种……因为他不是黑人，因为——
he's white that kind of gives him an in with readers who might have just dismissed the book and not you know um and he just sort of talks about what an unbelievable what an eye-opening so there is a massive there is a massive change in how he's treated it's called colossal yeah of course well he's literally sitting in a different part of the bus and and if he can and his instinctively you know he'll go to the sort of white seats count counters and things like that and people glare at him and he realizes you know he could be it's not plausible that he could be killed for being in the wrong place at the wrong time the wrong look at the wrong woman all that kind of thing um so that's a little a very unjolly reading recommendation for the yeah i mean 12 years a
他是白人，这让他能够走近那些可能原本会对这本书不屑一顾、根本不读的读者……他只是谈到了那种难以置信的、大开眼界的感觉——他的待遇发生了巨大的变化。这简直太惊人了。是的，当然，他字面意义上坐在了公交车的不同区域，如果他本能地……你知道的，他会走向白人专用的座位、柜台之类的地方，人们会怒视他，他意识到，你知道的，他可能会……在错误的时间出现在错误的地点、多看了不该看的女人一眼等等，都有可能被杀害——所以，这是一个非常不轻松的阅读推荐。是的，我的意思是，《为奴十二年》——
slave have you have you read it tom oh just haven't read it i've seen the film i've seen the film yeah i haven't read the book but i but i quite feel quite inspired by uh by doing you know thinking about this to go and read it well it's obviously a harrowing read yeah i mean unbelievably it's a harrowing story isn't it to go from you know you think you're off to play in a circle in the circus you end up being beaten on a plantation anyway um rather depressing subject yeah sorry about that but it's but it's but it's difficult isn't it i mean you know 12 days christmas ho ho ho jollity jollity but yeah i mean basically things are memorable in history often for terrible reasons they are aren't they so we've had murders and coups and enslavement and all kinds of horrors um and uh more fun and jollity after the break
你读过吗，汤姆？哦，我没读过。我看过电影，我看过电影，对。我没读过书，但我对去读这本书感到挺受启发的。好吧，这显然是一次痛苦的阅读体验。是的，我的意思是，难以置信，这是一个令人心碎的故事，不是吗？从你以为你是去马戏团表演，到最后在种植园里挨鞭子。无论如何，这是一个相当令人沮丧的话题。是的，对此我很抱歉。但这也是……这很难，不是吗？我的意思是，你知道的，圣诞节12天，欢欢喜喜，欢乐祥和。但我的意思是，基本上，历史上令人难忘的事情往往是因为可怕的原因，它们确实如此，不是吗？所以我们经历过了谋杀、政变、奴役和各种各样的恐怖事件，中场休息后会有更多有趣和欢乐的内容。
i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment More fun and jollity after the break. episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to uh the rest of history the fourth of january um and dominic you're going to cheer us up by giving your choice for something that happened on this day so it is the fourth of January. We're in 1960. Albert Camus, the French writer, has just been spending New Year in the south of France at his home in the Vaucluse in a village called Lomarin, which I've been to. A very pretty sort of Provençal kind of village.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。中场休息后将带来更多有趣和欢乐的内容。有关节目和现场演出门票的抢先预订，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，今天是1月4日。多米尼克，你要给我们讲一件今天发生的历史事件来让我们振作一下吗？所以今天是1月4日。时间是1960年。法国作家阿尔贝·加缪（Albert Camus）刚刚在法国南部的沃克吕兹（Vaucluse）省的一个名叫洛马兰（Lourmarin）的村庄度过新年，我去过那里。那是一个非常美丽的普罗旺斯风格的村庄。
Because, Tom, did you know that i spent a year living in provence i did peter male style yes i did as a language assistant and uh yeah i was teaching i was i was awful i was totally out of my job you were wonderful no it's terrible i because they gave you no using uh lazy to do your water it was awful tom i my french was so bacon and eggs and so i i'd sort of thought oh i'm terribly good at French. This will be an absolute triumph. And I arrived in France at the age of 21. And I remember going to try and open my bank account
因为，汤姆，你知道吗，我在普罗旺斯生活过一年。我真的去过，就像彼得·梅尔（Peter Mayle）风格的那样。是的，我是作为语言助理去的，而且，是的，我在教书，我当时糟糕透顶，我完全无法胜任这份工作。你当时很棒。不，我糟透了。因为他们没有给你任何用……用水的……这太糟糕了。汤姆，我的法语只会“培根和鸡蛋”，所以我想：“噢，我的法语太棒了。这绝对会是一场大胜利。”我21岁时到达法国。我记得我去尝试开一个银行账户，
so that I could receive my minimum wage from the French government. And I stood there in front of this bank manager and I realised I didn't know how to say, I'd like to open a bank account. Yeah, because all I'd done is, you know, I've been doing French literature. So I knew how to say, what do you think about... Madame Bovary is unhappy.
以便我能领到法国政府发放的最低工资。我站在那个银行经理面前，却意识到我根本不知道怎么说“我想开一个银行账户”。是的，因为我所做的一切，你知道的，我一直在研究法国文学。所以我知道怎么说：“你怎么看……包法利夫人很不快乐？”
Yeah, Madame Bovary. Yeah, but I was utterly out of my depth. I can remember some people, the students used to say to me, you speak quite good French, but why do you speak it with that ludicrous comic English accent? Which I found very insulting. Anyway, so L'Homme Marin, its claim to fame, is that this was the home of the writer Albert Camus.
是的，包法利夫人。是的，但我完全应付不来。我记得有些人，那些学生曾经对我说：“你法语说得挺好的，但你为什么带着那种滑稽可笑的英国口音？”我觉得这非常侮辱人。无论如何，洛马兰的成名之处在于，这里曾是作家阿尔贝·加缪的家。
And Camus, of course, is the sort of, he's a little bit, I don't want to damn him, but he's the teenager's favourite, isn't he? Yeah, he looks very cool with a cigarette. He looks terribly cool with a cigarette. his books about existentialism and so on although he he never defined himself as an existentialist no he didn't he was an absurdist yeah exactly and actually you know what uh particularly when the pandemic hit lots of people went back to their copies of la peste the plague and they said oh gosh this is actually, you know, so it's a genuinely, it's a really, really good book.
加缪当然是那种……他有点像……我并不是想贬低他，但他一直是青少年的最爱，不是吗？是的，他叼着香烟的样子非常酷。他叼着香烟的样子酷毙了。他关于存在主义的书籍等等，尽管他从未将自己定义为存在主义者。不，他没有，他是个荒诞主义者。是的，完全如此。事实上，你知道吗，特别是当大流行来临时，许多人重新翻开了他们的《鼠疫》，他们说：“噢，天哪，这实际上，你知道的……”所以这是一本真正意义上的、非常非常好的书。
And the fact that you read it when you were 18 and you thought it changed your, I mean, that's no reason to sort of curl your lip at it. Yeah, well, I feel a bit the same about Nietzsche, to be honest. Really? I was absolutely mad for Nietzsche when I was 18. And then I kind of thought, oh, I've grown out of that. And now I just thought, he's brilliant.
你在18岁时读过它，并且觉得它改变了你的人生，这并没有什么可让人撇嘴不屑的。是的，说实话，我对尼采也有点这种感觉。真的吗？我18岁时对尼采狂热至极。然后我有点觉得：“哦，我已经过了那个年纪了。”而现在我只是觉得：“他太才华横溢了。”
Yeah. So maybe that's Camus as well. That's sort of what I think about Camus actually because Camus was a I think genuinely a very impressive man much more impressive than Jean-Paul Sartre and he's a terrible man by comparison yeah uh so Camus I'm happy to accept that he's born in Algeria um and he wrestles all his life with the fact that he's the product of a kind of French Pied-Noir settler family in Algeria. So he was neutral in the Algerian war, wasn't he? He was. He was.
所以加缪可能也是这样。这差不多就是我对加缪的看法，因为加缪我认为确实是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，比让-保罗·萨特（Jean-Paul Sartre）impressive得多，相比之下萨特是个糟糕的人。是的，所以我很高兴地接受加缪出生在阿尔及利亚，他一生都在与这个事实做斗争：他是阿尔及利亚一种法国黑脚（Pied-Noir）定居者家庭的产物。所以他在阿尔及利亚战争中保持中立，对吗？是的，他是的。
And you can absolutely understand why. A lot of his sort of lefty friends in France sort of thought terribly badly of him and disavowed him for this. But his attitude was, which was sort of understandable. I mean, he had this famous line, I love justice, but I love my mother more was which was sort of understandable i mean he had this famous line um i love justice but i love my mother more um which was shocking to the kind of sartrean tendency because they thought abstract nouns were far more important than people yes kind of like i hope i would have the courage to portray my country over my friend exactly reversed so camus he he has been on this kind of intellectual journey so round about the second
你完全可以理解为什么。他在法国的一些左翼朋友对他的看法非常糟糕，并因此与他断绝关系。但他的态度是——这是某种程度上可以理解的。他有那句名言：“我热爱正义，但我更爱我的母亲。”这句名言……某种程度上可以理解的。他有那句名言：“我热爱正义，但我更爱我的母亲。”这让萨特主义倾向的人感到震惊，因为他们认为抽象名词比人重要得多。是的，有点像“我希望我有勇气选择我的国家而不是我的朋友”——正好相反。所以加缪，他一直走在这样一段知识分子之旅上。所以在第二——
world war just after the war he has a good war doesn't he i mean he has been on this kind of intellectual journey. So round about the Second World War, just after the war. And he has a good war, doesn't he? I mean, he has a really good war. So he edits Combat. Exactly. Which is a kind of resistance magazine. I mean, he's incredibly brave. He's one of the sort of intellectual heroes of the resistance.
世界大战期间，就在战争刚结束时，他经历了一次很好的战争，不是吗？我的意思是，他经历了一段这样的知识分子之旅。大约在第二次世界大战期间，就在战争刚结束时。他经历了一场很好的战争，不是吗？我的意思是，他确实经历了一场非常好的战争。所以他主编了《战斗报》（Combat）。没错。那是一本类似抵抗运动的杂志。我的意思是，他勇敢极了。他是抵抗运动中的知识分子英雄之一。
And afterwards, like so many people in that milieu, he is, so he's this young, very sort of suave, but obviously Algerian, so he's got a bit of an outsider side to him. Very good footballer. Goalkeeper, wasn't he? Goalkeeper, yeah. Where he played at university in Algiers. And he could have been really good, couldn't he?
战后，就像那个圈子里的许多人一样，他是——所以他是个年轻、非常温文尔雅、但显然是阿尔及利亚人，所以他身上带有一点局外人的色彩。非常出色的足球运动员。守门员，不是吗？守门员，是的。他在阿尔及尔上大学时踢过球。而且他本可以成为一个非常优秀的球员，不是吗？
He got some disease or something. Yeah, you never know whether these things are slightly exaggerated later because he's great. Like Jean-Paul II. Yeah, you never know whether these things are slightly exaggerated later because he's great. Like Jean-Paul II. Yeah, exactly. Jean-Paul II, who almost played in goal for Real Madrid or something, if you just believe some accounts. But actually probably just played goal twice or something.
他得了某种疾病还是怎么的。是的，你永远不知道这些事情后来是不是被稍微夸大了，因为他太伟大了。就像约翰·保罗二世一样。是的，你永远不知道这些事情后来是不是被稍微夸大了，因为他太伟大了。就像约翰·保罗二世一样。是的，完全如此。约翰·保罗二世，如果你相信某些说法的话，他差点就能为皇家马德里或其他什么球队担任守门员了。但实际上可能只是当过两次守门员什么的。
Anyway, Camus, he's always a bit of an outsider. He never quite fits in. And there's this period in the sort of late 40s where basically if you're a left-bank intellectual, you're very self-consciously left-wing. pro-stalin pro-stalin um camus some people say he's a bit more of an anarchist than a communist but certainly by the 50s he is moving he's sort of he's moving quite strongly in some ways to the center you know he's saying things like you know revolutionary violence is not a good thing so he's kind of of the French George Orwell. Yeah, he is exactly.
无论如何，加缪，他总是有点局外人色彩。他从不完全合群。在40年代末期有这样一段时期，基本上如果你是左岸知识分子，你就会非常自觉地偏向左翼。亲斯大林，亲斯大林……加缪，有些人说他与其说是共产主义者，不如说更接近无政府主义者，但到了50年代，他毫无疑问在转向，他在某种程度上非常强烈地向中间派靠拢。你知道，他开始说这样的话：“革命暴力不是一件好事。”所以他有点像是法国的乔治·奥威尔（George Orwell）。是的，他确实是。
He is exactly. I mean, there's lots of differences, so it's not an exact parallel, but you're absolutely right that he occupies that place of being the sort of... Ruff doing with a tremendous backstory like Orwell. Very opposed to Stalinism. Very opposed to Stalinism
他完全就是。我的意思是，有很多不同之处，所以这并不是一个完全精确的类比，但你绝对说得对，他占据了那个位置，成为那种……像奥威尔一样有着极其传奇的背景、行为粗犷的人。非常反对斯大林主义。非常反对斯大林主义，
and increasingly sort of interested in human detail, I suppose, and the texture of ordinary people's lives rather than grand ideological schemes. Abstractions. Yeah. So he's been given the Nobel Prize, which people see as, they see that as a Cold War thing. You know, they're almost encouraging him to back towards the centre
并且越来越关注人类的细节，我猜，关注普通人生活的质感，而不是宏大的意识形态方案。抽象概念。是的。所以他被授予了诺贝尔奖，人们认为——他们认为这是一场冷战政治的产物。你知道，他们几乎是在鼓励他回到政治中间派，
as a bit of a slap in the face. Well, because you know, the only person younger than him to get the Nobel Prize. Oh, that's a good one. I knew he was one of the youngest.
这有点像是在脸上狠狠打了一巴掌。好吧，因为你知道，他是获得诺贝尔奖的人当中比他年轻的仅有的……噢，这是一个好问题。我知道他是最年轻的几个人之一。
He was the second youngest. Kipling. I was about to say Kipling. So Kipling must have got it very early then. Kipling got it really early, yeah. But then Camus
他是第二年轻的。吉普林（Kipling）。我正要说吉普林。所以吉普林一定很早就获奖了。吉普林获奖确实非常早，是的。但加缪
was the second youngest. Two top writers. I'm very pleased to see them. I don't imagine they'd have got on, though, do you? No. No. Kipling would have had no time for Camus. No.
是第二年轻的。两位顶尖作家。我很高兴看到他们。不过我想象不出他们能合得来，是吧？不。不。吉普林根本不会把时间浪费在加缪身上。不。
All that sort of smoking and lounging around in cafes. Kipling would have been off on doing bushcraft or something. Anyway, so Camus, he's not terribly happy, I think, at the end of the 1950s, although he's got his Nobel Prize for some people in this old intellectual establishment. He's a bit persona non grata. So he's been down at his house in the South for New Year with his family
所有那种抽烟和在咖啡馆里闲逛的行为。吉普林大概会去搞什么丛林生存训练之类的了。无论如何，加缪，他对19th... 1950年代末期的状况并不是非常满意，尽管他获得了诺贝尔奖，但在某些人眼里，在这个老牌知识分子阶层里，他多少有点不受欢迎（persona non grata）。所以他去南方的新年宅邸和家人在一起，
and with his publisher, who's a man called Michel Gallimard and Gallimard's wife and daughter. And they decide they're going to go back to Paris. So on the 2nd of January, Camus' wife and children go off back to Paris on by train. And Gallimard says to Camus, well, I'll give you a lift. If you stay another couple of days, I'll give you a lift in my very fancy car. Camus, yeah, tremendous.
还有他的出版商，一个名叫米歇尔·伽利玛（Michel Gallimard）的人，以及伽利玛的妻子和女儿。他们决定回巴黎。所以在1月2日，加缪的妻子和孩子坐火车回了巴黎。而伽利玛对加缪说：“好吧，我捎你一程。如果你再多待几天，我可以用我那辆非常豪华的车捎你回去。”加缪：“好啊，太棒了。”
So on the 4th of January, they set off. And basically no one really knows what happens but they're not that far from Paris um when the car goes off the road and hits a plane tree and um Gallimard's wife and daughter escape unscathed uh Camus is killed instantaneously and Gallimard dies a few days later. And in the car is the 144-page manuscript of what Camus has written so far, the novel that he thinks will be his masterpiece, which is called Le Premier Homme, The First Man. And this is going to be his first really autobiographical novel
所以在1月4日，他们出发了。基本上没有人真正知道发生了什么，但离巴黎已经不是很远了，这时汽车冲出了路面，撞上了一棵悬铃木。伽利玛的妻子和女儿安然无恙，加缪当场身亡，伽利玛几天后也不治身亡。车里装着加缪迄今为止所写的144页的手稿，那部他认为将成为自己杰作的小说，名叫《第一个人》（Le Premier Homme, The First Man）。这将是他的第一部真正意义上的自传体小说，
about growing up in Algeria. So a very profound kind of subject, given that the Franco-Algerian war is absolutely in full swing. And he's going to be writing quite lyrically about the experience of growing up in Algeria. And of course that book is never finished, isn't published until I think something like 30 years later, Camus was killed.
讲述在阿尔及利亚长大的经历。这是一个非常深刻的主题，鉴于法阿战争正打得如火如荼，而他将以极具抒情色彩的方式书写在阿尔及利亚成长的经历。当然，那本书从未完成，直到加缪去世大约30年后的某个时候才出版。
And at the time, lots of people say, it must be a conspiracy. He must have been murdered by the KGB because of his move back towards the kind of political center. But almost certainly that's not the case. It was just sort of Gallimard's bad driving or whatever. I mean, who knows? Not Prince Philip.
当时，许多人说：“这一定是个阴谋。他一定是因为向政治中间派靠拢而被克格勃暗杀的。”但几乎可以肯定事实并非如此。这只是伽利玛糟糕的驾驶技术或诸如此类的原因造成的。我的意思是，谁知道呢？不是菲利普亲王（Prince Philip）。
No. Well, Prince Philip obviously has form with Gaelic car crashes. Yes. But in this case, no, he wasn't involved at all, as far as I know. So I studied French at school, a play by a cameo called Les Justes. Oh, yeah. I remember Les Justes. Revolutionaries, Russian revolutionaries.
不。好吧，菲利普亲王显然有涉及盖尔式汽车车祸的前科。是的。但在这种情况，不，据我所知他完全没有参与。所以我在学校学过法语，学过加缪的一部戏剧叫《正义者》（Les Justes）。哦，对。我还记得《正义者》。革命者，俄国革命者。
Yes. And the plot of that, they have to blow up a Russian prince or something in a car. That's it. In a carriage. So kind of death on roads is an eerie prefiguring. And he wrote a play about Caligula. He did, yeah.
是的。那部剧的情节是，他们必须在车里炸死一个俄国亲王什么的。就是这样。在一辆马车里。所以这种路上的死亡真是一种诡异的预示。他还写过一部关于卡利古拉（Caligula）的戏剧。他确实写过，是的。
Which I can remember doing at A-level. And it ends, Caligula was killed, and the last line is, he shouts, I'm still alive, as he's been killed. And the last line is, he shouts, I'm still alive as he's been killed. And then the play ends. Very profound. I have to say, I find all those 50s French plays, which I studied a lot, I find them terrible. And indeed acted in.
我记得我在高级水平考试（A-level）时学过。结局是卡利古拉被杀了，最后一句台词是，他在被杀的同时大喊：“我还活着！”而戏剧就此结束。非常深刻。我必须说，我发现所有那些50年代的法国戏剧——我学过很多——我都觉得糟糕透顶。而且我甚至还参演过。
Yeah, well, the Jean-Henri. I mean, I'm always happy to mention that. I think the listeners have probably heard enough about that for the time being. But I think they're just, so all those Soitre plays, Les M plays les moussales and stuff dirty hands they're basically people just standing and talking to each other endlessly what is violence you know all this they're dramatically utterly inert um i think but i think camus novels and he wrote a and the myth of sisyphus yes i must think that sisyphus is happy yeah uh i, that's a kind of memorable tagline. Yeah, it's a good image.
是的，好吧，让-亨利……我的意思是，我总是很高兴提及这一点。我想听众们对此大概已经听得够多了。但我觉得它们就是……所有那些萨特的戏剧，如《肮脏的手》之类的，基本上就是人们站在那里没完没了地互相交谈：什么是暴力？你知道，所有这些。它们在戏剧性上完全是死寂的，我认为。但我认为加缪的小说——他写过《西西弗神话》——是的，我必须认为西西弗是快乐的。是的。那是一个令人难忘的标语。是的，这是一个很好的意象。
I mean, that's his sort of statement of the absurd, isn't it? He also wrote some very interesting short stories called Exile in the Kingdom. A lot of them set in Algeria, which are kind of quite weird. And they've been attacked by critics as a bit orientalizing. But that's kind of inevitable, I suppose, if you're growing up as part of that sort of settler community surrounded by North African Muslims. You know what?
我的意思是，那是他对荒诞的宣言，不是吗？他还写了一些非常有趣的短篇小说，名叫《流放与王国》（Exile and the Kingdom）。其中很多故事以阿尔及利亚为背景，显得非常诡异。它们曾遭到批评家的抨击，认为带有某种东方主义色彩。但这某种程度上是不可避免的，我猜，如果你作为一个定居者社区的一部分长大，周围环绕着北非穆斯林的话。你知道吗？
The very first piece of research I ever did, Tom, was on French colonial Algeria. Yes, you've mentioned this. You have mentioned this. A pogrom in the city of Constantine in 1934. And, well, we're going to do it. We're going to do the Algerian War. That'd be a great subject.
我做过的第一项研究，汤姆，就是关于法属殖民地阿尔及利亚的。是的，你提过这个。你提到过这个。1934年君士坦丁市的一场大屠杀。而且，好吧，我们打算做这个主题。我们要讲阿尔及利亚战争。那将是一个很棒的主题。
It's really fascinating. And, of course, people who came to our live show will know we are great fans of the Battle of Algiers. So lots to look forward to on that front. We've got more Gallic conduct tomorrow, actually. Yes, we have, yes. And a stunning rebuke for people who've sometimes said there's not enough French history on this podcast.
这真的非常引人入胜。而且，当然，来参加我们现场演出的朋友们都知道，我们是《阿尔及利亚之战》的超级粉丝。所以在这方面有很多值得期待的内容。事实上，我们明天还有更多高卢相关的内容。是的，我们有，是的。对于那些有时说这个播客中法国历史不够多的人来说，这是一个惊人的回击。
We're absolutely wallowing in French history. Yeah. We've actually got two French themed topics tomorrow, but we mustn't reveal what they are. We need the tension cranked up. But tomorrow is obviously the most important day of the year, 5th of January, because it's my birthday.
我们绝对沉浸在法国历史中。是的。事实上，我们明天有两个法国主题的话题，但我们绝不能透露它们是什么。我们需要保持悬念。但明天显然是一年中最重要的日子，也就是1月5日，因为那是我的生日。
Tom Holland's birthday. What a great moment. So of course it's not, you get two birthdays, don't you? You're like the queen. Because you have your real birthday and then you have your official Twitter birthday where people, teenagers in America. Yes, probably. Send you.
汤姆·霍兰德的生日。多棒的时刻。所以，当然，其实不是，你有两个生日，对吧？你就像女王一样。因为你有你真正的生日，然后你还有你的官方推特（Twitter）生日，美国的青少年们——是的，大概吧——会发信息给你。
Tell them they want to marry me, which is lovely. You know, though Sadie doesn't really. Always comes as a shock to her when she finds it. Yeah. What are all these messages? 22-year-old in Rioaneiro is offering herself to me i just want to say no none of that nonsense yeah right we'll see you tomorrow goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
告诉他们他们想嫁给我，这太可爱了。你知道的，虽然萨蒂（Sadie）并不是真的这么想。她每次发现这些时总是感到很震惊。是的。“这些都是什么消息？里约热内卢的一个22岁女孩向我求爱……”我只想说，没有那些无聊的废话。好吧，我们明天见，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。有关加更节目、抢先收听、无广告音频
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们聊天社区的权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。